[Music]
thank you very much the pleasure to be
back here I also have a long history in
Boston I went to Boston College was a
student government leader and then an
anti-war leader so I've been organizing
most of my adult life and I relished the
opportunity to to organize around this
issue I've been doing it in Washington
from 35 years but now we have this new
phenomenon this new mass movement that
has risen that is unlike any movement
I've seen before in this country it is
deeper it is broader it is newer it is
spontaneous and it is emerging all over
the country and the people that are
interested in taking to the streets to
speak out for women's rights and human
rights and labor rights are also
interested in the issues of war and
peace and the and that's what makes this
nuclear issue so relevant for this
moment because while we can talk about
the waste that the trillion dollar triad
will generate while we can talk about
the nuts the people are who would
advocate these new weapons and these new
missions for these weapons it's really
the what's happened since Donald Trump's
election that is motivating this
movement that is grabbing people's
attention unlike any other period that
I've seen on April 15th a whole lot of
us thought we were going to go to war
that's when Kim Jong un was said he was
going to test a by nuclear nuclear test
or perhaps a ballistic missile test and
the president of united states said he
assented Armada
down to the coast of Korea and it looked
like we were heading for conflict we
dodged that nuclear bullet but that
crisis isn't over so to help us
understand this what we're up against
where we are now let me just give a
quick 10 minute speech I haven't quite
I haven't given this talk before I just
made it up this morning I'm calling it
the three crazies the three crazies to
understand where we are on the first
crazy is the President of the United
States now we this is a topic that is
being approached quite gingerly in the
public discourse you see some people say
Joe Scarborough he's not crazy like a
fox he's just crazy he's separated from
reality George Will if you haven't read
this column from two days ago go read
this column the President of the United
States he has a dangerous disability
says he does not know what it's like to
know something for all of you have been
studying epistemology mr. Malla gee in
college we're talking about that the
essence what is knowledge how do we know
something the president of the United
States does not seem to know anything
and I'm going to I'm not going to go too
deep into this Hawaiian I just want to
let you know that in dinner
conversations in Washington in ways that
people wouldn't say in public there is a
consensus that the president the United
States is crazy that one of the reasons
that Jared and Ivanka and others are
there are to control him to steer him to
monitor him you let him out for too long
and bizarre things start to happen right
okay so then you couple this with the
unnerving fact that the president of
United States is the only person who has
the authority to launch a nuclear weapon
and once he gives the order that order
cannot be countermanded that's why a
military officer follows him around 24
hours a day seven days a week
can't be more than one minute from him
when the president is sleeping he's
outside the bedroom when the president
is golfing he's in a golf cart by find
it when the president goes into an
elevator the officer gets into the
elevator with him he's right there
because he has the command and control
football the nuclear football he opened
it up and there the options there the
codes there are the things that the
president can do and he can give that
order at any time we don't have to be
under attack for him to do this it's his
authority we call the nuclear weapons
the press
weapons and once he gives the order no
one can countermand and there is no
meeting of the cabinet there is no
meeting of the Joint Chiefs there was no
time to appeal something to the Supreme
Court no it's gone and four minutes
after he gives the order missiles go
flying we have about 400 ICBMs in silos
- scattered across the Great Plains from
North Dakota to Montana each carries a
warhead 20 times the bomb the power of
the bomb that destroyed Hiroshima we
have five submarine-launched ballistic
missiles on high alert at all times
under the end of the oceans they have
another 460 warheads each of those 30
times more powerful than the Hiroshima
bomb so you have a total of about 500
missiles with 860 warheads with the
equivalent of 15,000 Hiroshima you do
that you launch that force you destroy
everything that humanity has created
over the millennia as Richard Nixon says
I can go into my office pick up the
phone and in 30 minutes 70 million
people would be dead that is an under
estimate now you would kill billions of
people and the president of President
alone has that order and what's
encouraged this is so the first crazy is
the problem we have in the Oval Office
the second crazy is the policy itself
why on earth do we have a policy that
crazy why does one human being have the
authority to kill all other human beings
within 30 minutes it is insane
fortunately you're getting reactions to
this some of it Massachusetts led I was
just at a press conference two days ago
in the Capitol with Senator Ed Markey
and Senator ted Lieu a rising star and
both of them have introduced a bill to
restrict the president's first use of
nuclear weapons to say no Congress has
the authority to declare war and that
should matter when it's the most
important war of all a nuclear war you
want to be the first to use a nuclear
weapon mr. president you have to come to
Congress and get authorization we now
have 34 co-sponsors on that bill
so it's a piece of legislation that's
actually moving so when you hear about
Marquis Lu Marquis Lu that is not a
filly running in the Kentucky Derby
today Marquis Lu is probably one of the
most important pieces of legislation we
can promote here it will it pass the
republican-controlled Congress no but we
want to increase the attention to it
want to increase support for it a number
of organizations that we work with the
plowshares funds are talking about doing
what you guys are doing here going to
the municipal level getting City
Council's and state legislators to pass
language on this if you can't get it
done through Congress let's get it done
outside Congress let's build up that
kind of support and finally the third
crazy
the third crazy and the people that are
crazy that are not us didn't and we have
to contain that there are dangerous
unstable people out there who would use
nuclear weapons if they could and you
can start with Kim jong-un would he use
a nuclear weapon I think he might this
is not just about deterrence for them
what advice has got a nuclear weapon
would they use it I think they would so
you have problems of nuclear weapons
fretting about the world and that
relates directly to our the size of our
arsenal you cannot convince people to
shrink their Arsenal's as long as US is
continues to grow as long as we say we
have to spend a trillion dollars over
the next 25 years for new and better and
more capable weapons and keep designing
new targets and new missions for them of
course other country is going to do it
so what we do on our disarmament level
affects what other countries do what
other groups do the availability of Isis
to get a weapon and finally you have to
understand the situation in South Asia
another crazy situation with two
nuclear-armed rivals squaring off each
other people are dying on the Indian
Pakistan border every day there was a
hot fight going on over Kashmir now now
this week this month they both have 120
nuclear weapons that fight could
escalate and if it does get into a
battle between these two armies almost
every war game that's ever been played
about conventional conflict in South
Asia over the last 20 years goes nuclear
there's no reason to doubt that they
won't so we have those three crazy
problems our president our policy the
others out in the world I'm optimistic
that we can do something about it not
because I see rational thinking
returning to Washington but because I
see this mass movement growing on the
world and as you said Jonathan it's our
job to how to figure to understand the
intersectionality of our issues and the
movements issues to bring them to be one
one in the same as Kamala Harris said at
the women's March January 21st which
began the sub surge you want to talk
about women's issues let's talk about
national security
that's a women's issue and that's the
kind of attitude we need to foster we
need to do to find the Alliance to turn
this mass movement into a force that can
change not just nuclear policy but the
United States of America thank you very
much one of the things that has kept me
somewhat saying about this whole issue
is the sense and I don't know any I'm
sure no one can prove it is that someone
like Secretary of Defense mattis has
already made arrangements just the way
he did during the Watergate crisis to
order other people in the top level yeah
not to follow any orders from the
lunatik in the Oval Office I know you
you can't possibly know whether or not
that's been set up but what did you have
gut tell you about that my gut tells me
no and here's why
and the only the only parallel situation
to the one we're currently in was in the
last few weeks of the Nixon
administration when under impeachment
threat Nixon was drinking heavily and
this is well documented drinking heavily
and wandering the halls of the White
House at night talking to portraits on
the wall and at that moment secretary to
portraits on the why is that but
Secretary of Defense Jim Schlesinger
there wasn't Haig Schlesinger told the
officers including the nuclear command
that nuclear officer carrying the
nuclear football if the president gives
you an order check with me first
now that is unconstitutional that is
illegal he cannot do that I think we're
all glad that we did but it was under
extremists I doubt very much that the
secretary defense is saying that now at
this moment if it if the president heard
about that I think the secretary advance
would lose his job so I just don't think
that's happening remember the chain of
command doesn't have to include the
secretary defense it's the president
that gives the order if the Secretary of
Defense's in vet is available the chain
goes through the Secretary of Defense to
the commander of the military force to
the launch officers but you don't need
the only one you need in that chain is
the president well my gut tells me that
Madison wouldn't have taken the job
unless he felt he could do that but of
course it's completely unbounded I seems
very level-headed he is and we're lucky
he's there I know Jim mattis had met Jim
mattis he's a good man and his hours
circuit-breaker but there's no guarantee
and he doesn't have control I mean
remember the Saturday night massacre
under Nixon going Attorney General he
told him to fire the special prosecutor
and attorney Elliot Richardson a
Massachusetts man resigned well then
they they put the second in command and
he refused they fired him they got the
third guy he gave the order that's
pretty much a situation you have you
have to remember the president United
States is the president of the United
States and everybody else works for him
one of the quick question does the
Markey loop bill include an order that
might occur during a launch on warning
situation
no is only the first use so it doesn't
take away the ability of the president
to launch after we've been attacked well
but but radar is my radar my also under
attack no it doesn't it doesn't include
that which is a risk in itself but in
order to even get a chance of having
this bill being considered
had to limited Thank You someone else
turn to the mic and I don't know if
machi Lu is exactly the answer or not
but what's so important is you see
leading political figures endorsing this
pushing this so one thing we could all
do is encourage the other members there
are people who work for us to get on
board and endorse this bill as well can
we you look at any of the other nations
that have nuclear weapons to see if
there is a better safeguard on Monaco
Russia has almost the same plan so does
the UK so does France so they all have a
modified form of alert Russia's almost
identical to ours they also have about
800 warheads on air trigger alert which
is the problem the country actually with
some of the best are is India and
Pakistan which stores their weapons
unassembled so it's not a hair-trigger I
mean it takes hours or days to be able
to put your nuclear weapons in place but
as tensions increase both those
countries are reconsidering their
doctrines and and therefore we
considering that their deployment
options if the key thing that we could
do is to file to something like that one
take our nuclear weapons or hair-trigger
alert this is a cold war anachronism
take them down so it takes hours of days
to launch and even getting the point
where you take the warheads off the
missiles so what that's then you really
are preventing an accidental launch or
launch under a miscalculation thank you
[Applause]
[Music]